olá antes mais e obrigada todas as tops
que ouvi hoje nunca pensei que uma coisa
não acontece nada com o futebol fosse
inspirada tanto porque na realidade não
liga nenhuma futebol branco toca todas
as outras também é moldes nada a ver com
minha vida tudo a ver com a minha vida
primeiro o símbolo da normalização a
seletiva normalização pra eu ver ninguém
na qualidade de pessoa
sou músico faço música mas uma pessoa
também o que é normalizar sua ativamente
o que eu quero normalizar
quais são os símbolos que eu quero
trazer pra frente sei que muitos de
vocês já estão habituados a ver nesse
contexto mais eloqüente e e e não falar
pastelaria basicamente mas também existe
eu vou tentar mantê lo até o fim
[Música]
o que eu quero dizer pra frente como
símbolo o que quer normalizar
como é que eu quero mascarar o facto de
estar a dizer vai com o pai pai como a
mãe como o que interessa no meio de uma
música aparece um remix da música baiana
maior porque eu quero ir para a frente
com este conceito mascarados por que é
que eu vou mascarar as coisas que eu
quero tornar normais aumenta porque vai
ser a única maneira que eu vou passar
por baixo da ponte chegaram apetite de
ser pai com pai e mãe como em alcains
igual mas se eu fizer uma música que não
tem nada a ver com isso ele séries no
meio da música
talvez a segunda terceira quarta vez que
vai pensar não querem mais que eu estou
dizendo aqui uma mãe daquela música
tanto que não vai encarecer continente
lembrando ensinar ninguém fazer nada
obviamente salmito faz música que
aprendeu por acaso não chega não pensei
e por acaso teve a ajuda da internet e
tem instrumentos e faz música
é mas é isso estão a querer construir
alguma coisa tragam os vossos símbolos
para frente né não preciso falar sobre o
que não querem ser menor que seja normal
para uma frente o que vocês querem que
seja normal pagam à frente da construção
que tragam para frente aquilo que diz
alguma coisa em termos construtivos e
rosa murcha e uma rosa tezza rosa murcha
autores construção com o processo para a
construção
quem são vocês o que é que vocês estudam
o que vocês gostam de fazer pedra pedra
em quanto tempo a estudar eu perco mesmo
tempo uma tripla de cerca de duas horas
de vídeos do anúncio do pne pontos anos
90 o que está ali funciona para mim como
zico para mim como performa tudo voltou
a estudar
estou a aprender tempo a saber quem é
que eu sou mas ao mesmo tempo e isso
vamos tratar nunca mais abaixo no dragão
e no pio
ao mesmo tempo eu tô pronto para
construir os meus símbolos e
desconstruir os longas quito
eu quero ouvir músicas opinión conforme
hoje todas as músicas que oiço música a
música dos balcãs mas no momento de
construção
eu tenho que fazer desses símbolos para
não colar aquilo que te ouvir para ouvir
duas horas de música e pimpão não quer
dizer que vou fazer um álbum sobre o pne
bons quer dizer que eu tô a consumir
algo que eu vou ter que destruir para
dar lugar a uma nova construção a nova
próxima coisa que vou fazer é super
importante
é importante também a nível de
ferramentas o que é que vocês usam para
desconstruir o que vocês usam para
depois de não terem mais símbolos
consumidos
o que vocês usam para matar para vos ao
tomar tarde para vos mutilar todos esses
símbolos vocês receberam é importante
estudar isto não vai pagar e não vai
fazer música como via de destruição
máxima eu quero fazer música sempre
dentro da ordem
eu uso a ordem e usa a matemática usa os
números usa os processos normais de
construção das coisas para o
questionário da ordem
eu não trago o caos para frente para
questionar a ordem logo imediatamente
eu faço as coisas infiltrada mente eu
construo as coisas de forma a aparecer
em uma cozinha defensiva e de repente as
coisas morrem antes
às vezes o som bem eu às vezes sou um
boi é aceitação da da não permanência
aceitação da dualidade eu tenho eu como
como artista e como pessoa tem que
aceitar que eu sou tudo ao mesmo tempo
as pessoas às vezes vêem me dizem ao
cair 1 mil do da net que faz música da
netwall outras pessoas venham instagram
me dizem o álbum mil descreve as cenas
que só essas duas coisas que eu estava
lá fora com alguns voluntários em
algumas minas estavam a dizer quem é
difícil estar aqui e eu vi que eu tô
aqui também mas duas não sou bem
ocupadas uma estrela mas também sou uma
pessoa bem ocupada brasil agora tô aqui
o ato frente e que o que eu quero como
cocoa come dualidade é exatamente isso
eu quero apresentar mate foram contesto
pessoa eu sou uma pessoa prática só no
contexto do espetáculo eu vou ser o teu
performance eu vou ser a pessoa que está
a tentar te eu vou ser a pessoa que
eventualmente botar acredite ser alguma
coisa que eu sempre vesti dizer eu tenho
que aceitar toda a minha qualidade para
poder realmente chegar às pessoas
eu tenho que admitir conforme aquela
criança que eu também sou aquela criança
e também sua mãe dela que está a tentar
ao mesmo tempo pensar nas horas e minha
filha não faz trinta por uma linha e ser
essas duas coisas admite tudo o que se é
faz parte fulcral para que o que eu
também sou
[Música]
o seguro que vocês fazem com a
construção a construção é um seguro de
mortalidade
tudo que você se construírem e tudo aqui
o que eu falei até agora e que tem um
fim de semana com música talvez alguns
de vocês vão gostar possam conhecer
também não voltará a falar muito
especificamente disse que já tem
passagem por mães de grama como ela
tirar cada uma uma briga lá fora
o instagram é realmente quem eu sou o
que eu escrevo no instagram é realmente
aquilo que eu penso pessoas às vezes me
perguntam machucar né é uma personagem
mais uma pessoa na atualidade
eu sou corna e também o tiago pessoas
duas coisas eu não sou corna quando vou
comprar paulo e supermercados espalhados
mas que ela se eu quiser fazer alguma
coisa mais especial já você conar e é um
pecado nisso que se prende à construção
como julgados como é que eu posso aqui
100 anos daqui a 200 anos eventualmente
internet em desistir do planeta em
distritos como é que eu posso dizer aos
meus filhos meus netos só até aquela
criança quem eu fui o que eu tento
ensinar eventualmente acho que eu tenho
que ensinar o que eu tentei aprender o
que eu aprendi enquanto tinha ficado em
campo o que é que eu transformei para
dizer tudo aquilo que eu quis dizer
enquanto pessoa enquanto artista em
quantos irão eventualmente enquanto
enquanto um puto teve acesso a um pc e
um programa de fazer música
basicamente é basicamente isto eu passei
um caso rápido mais tinha tinha ensaiado
isso mil vezes
esse é o conceito tamanho da do mundo
ser imprevisível e dualidade
eu ensaiei este três vezes e todas as
três vezes que olho no tempo certo
agora não está a calhar porque porque eu
nunca falei foi uma das pessoas porque
eu nunca ganhei um discurso da dívida
não conduza esse senhor e claro
inclusive andam óbvio que isso agora
mudou no cubo
é óbvio agora faltam dez minutos e eu
acabei todos os meus tópicos e agora o
que é canto
hoje não mas aí mais um mais um
basicamente é isso todos estes conceitos
e eu fiz isto no hotel
basicamente o que estava a fazer parte
da minha dos meus apontamentos todos
estes conceitos servem pra dizer
exatamente isto
eu posso querer trazer um lanche ambos
pra frente
trouxe o que eu quero analisar o que eu
quero que seja corrente não tendo que os
barrados isso de uma forma bélica na
cara das pessoas
como é que um autor que construiu para
criar a minha nova coisa já foi
como é que eu sou um boião bebel mesmo
tempo muitas vezes eu tenho seis anos de
idade
muitas vezes tem 72 eu nem sequer andar
não quero mexer com a lado nenhum
tudo isso faz parte depois do meu
processo criativo
tudo que está aqui entra diariamente na
minha vida eu tenho que fazer todos
estes passos para ser quem eu sou e se
isso alguma coisa se eu já fiz algum
espetáculo se eu já fui a um álbum
festival com um monte de gente
foi porque eu faço isto é no fundo ser
uma pessoa nada mais é do que isso
vocês têm alguma questão que não está
disposto a ver com questões quer seja
exposto eu publico colocar os paulo uma
questão mas o que me toque é isto
antes de eu ter todos os processos que
eu possa ter para fazer coisa que seja
mais ou menos denial com base nas mortes
nas melhores maiores nas piores memórias
da minha vida eu não posso fazer nada
disse eu não for uma pessoa isto a cair
muitas toques que houve que hoje tanto é
exatamente isso e não sou nada oficial
só um puto e é base é essa eu somente um
ponto que fez música e escreve assim ter
sorte que tive sorte porque eu fui uma
pessoa é só isto
[Aplausos]